My uncle came home
from prison when I was 15,
but a few months later he was sent back.
The whole experience made me pay attention
to the criminal justice system
for the first time.
I started talking
to researchers, advocates
and eventually to the people
who run the US prison system.
What surprised me most
in those conversations
was something they all agreed on.
Everyone, the left, the right,
advocates, agencies
agreed that change was being
slowed down by bad data.
Data that was scattered,
stale, incomplete.
Data that made it really hard
to know what was working.
Data so bad that people
who had done everything
that they needed to do
to be released from prison
were still stuck in the system.
Altogether,
bad data means that hundreds
of thousands of people
are in prison and on probation and parole
who don't need to be there.
People like Kate.
In 2018, Kate was sentenced to four years
on probation for a drug charge.
At sentencing, the judge told her
that if she was doing well,
she could cut that sentence in half.
Today she's sober, employed,
has stable housing,
she's got kids who are doing great.
She did everything the judge asked,
but she's still on probation.
Kate's parole officer, Allison, has been
an officer in Idaho for six years.
And she's great at her job.
But her job is kind of impossible.
She is responsible for 90 people
who each need to do 21 things
in order to be released.
And those 21 things live
in five different databases.
So earned credits in one place,
drug tests in another,
fines and fees in another.
Phone reception is bad
in most parole offices,
so to get the code to log
into each system,
she'd have to go to the parking lot.
And she would have to do that
for 90 people every day manually
just to know who had already done
everything they needed to do
to be released.
So you can see how people
fall through the cracks.
And it's hundreds of thousands of people.
Nobody likes this.
I have spent the last three years
working with the people
who run state prison systems,
and I can tell you
that nobody likes the fact
that people are stuck in the system
because databases
aren't talking to each other.
It got like this because we have
a fragmented system
that grew really fast.
Starting in the '70s
we saw runaway growth at every level
of the US justice system.
State prisons,
county jails, city police departments
all running their own
collection of databases
that don't talk to each other.
Fast forward to today
and both sides of the aisle
have fought to undo that growth,
passing common-sense laws that let people
who are succeeding earn their way out.
But the data that an officer like Allison
would need to actually enact those laws
is still scattered across
all those different systems.
Criminal justice reform is complex.
But this specific part of the problem
has a very clear solution.
We can bring the data together.
We can build tools for decision-makers.
And those tools can directly translate
to more people getting out of the system
and staying out of the system.
That's what we do at Recidiviz.
We're a nonprofit engineering team.
And for officers like Allison, we built
a tool that answers three questions.
Who is eligible for release,
literally right now;
who's almost eligible, but just
needs to do one more thing,
like send in a picture of their pay stub.
And who actually needs help
getting treatment,
getting a job, finding housing.
It's the simplest tool
that you can imagine,
but it means that suddenly Allison
can help the people who actually need it
and help everyone else
get back to their lives.
We launched this tool
in Idaho six months ago.
Within weeks, Kate was released.
Within months, five percent
of people on probation and parole
had either been moved
to lower levels of supervision
or moved out of the criminal
justice system entirely.
(Applause)
Five percent.
Let's say we scaled
just that to all 50 states.
That alone would impact
200,000 people like Kate.
And it's just the first step.
That's one piece of the puzzle.
We need better data at every level
of criminal justice decision making.
So that corrections leaders can see
which treatment programs work.
So that supervisors can find
and fix these broken processes
that pull people back in.
So that policymakers can see
which laws are holding people back.
These are the leaders that Americans
are looking to to reduce incarceration,
to reduce racial disparities,
to save taxpayer dollars
and to do it all safely.
We're asking them to make
pretty bold changes while flying blind.
Data can't fix the US justice system,
but it can help 200,000
people who are stuck.
It can show us
which strategies are working.
It can give us the confidence
that the laws that we fight for
are actually helping the people
that they're designed to help.
We started this work
because it felt like a clear place
for software engineers to pitch in.
But it turns out that getting data
to decision-makers
is one of the most promising
strategies we have
for transforming the whole system.
So today, three years, eight states
and thousands of people later,
feels like we're just getting started.
Thank you.
(Applause)